i'm hans
uh and i'm the founder of handstand
studio um for repair
is a project uh that where we wanted to
investigate and contend with ideals
uh associated with uh the concept of
repair
we invited the the public to volunteer
uh broken objects objects of disrepair
objects that are spoiled
at the same time you know the exhibition
was really a response
to the consumerist culture the culture
of you know throwing away things uh
rather easily my name is han wai
and i am the creative director and
co-founder of lanza vaca and wire design
studio
we were given an archetypal casio
wristwatch
strap had become brittle over the years
we have repaired the broken watch by
encasing its essential time keeping
component in a super normal cuboid form
hand crafted from noble walnut wood both
parts of the cuboid enclosure are hewn
from
one single block of walnut a continuous
hole shows the time on the front as well
as allows for easy access for the
owner's finger to
push and detach the watch for future
service
and maintenance the watch is kept in
place just by
surface friction in a hand carved cavity
the front cover is also attached by
friction with four brass pins
that also serve as noon 3 6 and 9
o'clock markers our studio understands
that the watch is a precious memento
from the owners growing up years
and honors that memory by framing and
reassigning it into a product archetype
that will prominently exist
and function in the owner's home for
many days and season of life to come
hi my name is alvin this is clara and we
are from italy hoku
we received a cup with a broken handle
and the first instinct was to just glue
it back but then
we felt hey this is actually a good
pretext to
reintroduce the gesture of drinking
without handles because actually in
the asian context we do have a lot of
cups without
a handle so our approach was to grind
down the
the sharp parts that were caused by the
breakage
we put a layer of resin on it
we're trying to really introduce to the
uh the owner
eventually is to to continue to drink
from the cup
and to in a way drink with her hands so
the hand will start to feel the warmth
of the beverage you know
we included a booklet that actually
details
like how you can possibly use it without
the handle
and a little short write-up i mean to
drink without the handle
what is it like and i hope that she's
able to experience it on her own
yeah and also when she's using it with
her sister
in their daily lives
you